[Musique]
françois fillon vous êtes le benjamin de
la nouvelle assemblée puisque vous avez
27 ans vous avez été élu député de la 4e
circonscription de la sarthe et dès le
premier tour
vous remplacez donc joël le theule avec
qui vous avez fait des débuts de votre
carrière
avant la disparition de l'ancien
ministre vous êtes allez vous au palais
bourbon dès la semaine dernière puisque
élu au premier tour
nous allons revenir si vous le voulez
sur la compagnie qu'est ce que ça peut
apporter la campagne un jeune comme vous
ça une campagne électorale c'est un
moment privilégié de contacts avec une
circonscription mais c'est aussi un peu
une période irréel
vous avez beaucoup d'amis qui surgissent
de partout pour vous aider il vous avez
des thèmes à défendre devant des sous
les préaux d'école c'est c'est quelque
chose d'irréel
et c'est en même temps un des temps les
plus forts de la vie politique
et puis alors il y a le fait que vous
êtes députés de l'opposition alors
est-ce que c'est facile pour un jeune
député d'entrer à l'assemblée nationale
dans l'opposition ou est-ce que c'est
moins facile que si vous étiez encore
dans la majorité
finalement c'est une question qu'une
fois répondre dans quelques jours parce
que j'ai pas fais ma rentrée encore
alors sollicité d'entrée va-t-il entrer
tout de suite comme ça dans l'opposition
une autre membre du rpr jean relate bien
sûr que nous n'ayons pas
le pool le pouvoir mais je crois que
pour un jeune de mon âge c'est une
période exceptionnelle et que je vais
pouvoir grain me faire les dents à la
lutte politique dans les rangs de
l'opposition
alors quelle place pensez vous tenir
parmi les ténors du rpr place modeste
certainement j'ai l'intention de traque
un petit peu de travailler à côté de
jacques chirac de monsieur messmer
monsieur couve de murville chacun à sa
place moi j'apporterai mon inexpérience
et leur expérience mais j'apporte aussi
nié une façon nouvelle de voir les
choses et j'ai bien l'intention de
prendre ma part de responsabilité
modeste mais qu'est ce que vous comptez
faire concrètement dans cette assemblée
voter des lois si si on nous en propose
qui correspondent à nos à nos souhaits
bien sûr et puis assurer la fonction de
contrôle qui est la fonction normale
d'un parlementaire et en particulier
dans le domaine de la défense qui est
celui qui m'a toujours le plus bas est
grillé participer à une commission de
l'effort tout à fait alors député pour
vous c'est quoi c'est une c'est une
profession comme une honte et faire un
métier où c'est une vocation
je crois qu'aucun des deux termes ne
convient sont les circonstances qui vous
amène à entrer dans dans l'arène
politique ya un aspect professionnel il
ya un aspect vocation ya pas de
définition le premier jour vous allez
être assis je crois à près de marcel
dassault
puisque c'est lui le doyen peut-être un
petit peu impressionnants comme ça de se
retrouver le plus jeune près du doyen je
crois que c'est ce qui est le plus
impressionnant est le plus intimidant
alors la vie de député en province et
les préaux vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure ça va être aussi le bal des
pompiers tout ça ça va changer votre vie
j'imagine oui ça c'est l'aspect que ne
connaissais pas je traite les dossiers
dans le passé aujourd'hui
il ya cette fonction de représentation
vous savez elle est passionnante parce
qu'elle donne le contact direct avec les
habitants d'une région et c'est là que
vous pouvez vous rendre compte des
problèmes et de la façon dont le blason
une dernière question françois fillon
vous avez vous allez être quelqu'un qui
va défendre des grandes options sur le
plan national
ou alors vous vous sentez à l'assemblée
nationale là pour défendre vos
concitoyens ceux de votre ville ce
nouveau village
je crois que les deux sont
indissociables mais les dossiers
économiques de ma région sont ceux qui
passeront en priorité merci françois
fillon le député de la 4e
circonscription de la sarthe c'est
françois fillon qui sera le benjamin de
l'assemblée nationale le plus jeune
député de france en sorte françois
fillon rpr est âgé de 27 ans seulement
il succède à joël le theule dont il fut
l'assistant parlementaire le rpr
françois fillon avec 51,1 % des
suffrages a été élu au premier tour
le tout jeune député est titulaire d'une
licence en droit il est diplômé de
l'institut d'études politiques
françois fillon a commencé sa carrière
politique comme attaché parlementaire à
sablé sur sarthe
cette ville où nous le retrouverons
françois fillon si vous avez dit est de
trois ans que vous seriez aujourd'hui
que je ne puisse être en ce moment les
crues non certainement pas je ne
m'attendais pas du tout à être élu
député à 27 ans j'étais déjà dans
l'ombre de joël tel depuis cinq ans
puisque j'étais son collaborateur chargé
des dossiers sarthois en particulier et
j'espérais bien être ce collaborateur
pendant encore de longues années
c'est donc pour moi une situation
nouvelle est une surprise la carrière
politique de françois fillon est
étroitement liée à joël le theule de 76
à 78 il fut son assistant parlementaire
avant de le suivre durant deux ans au
ministère des transports et de la
défense comme chargé de mission à son
cabinet devenu à 27 ans le benjamin de
l'assemblée
il succède dès le premier tour à joël le
theule dans sa circonscription
après une vie politique vieille de
quatre mois durant laquelle il accède au
conseil général de la sarthe riz à la
mairie de sablé comme adjoint au maire
françois fillon qui s'orientaient vers
le journalisme est conscient de la
difficulté d'assumer les reee
hb d'un homme qui a profondément marqué
la vie politique de la rue il faut que
bien sûr nous poursuivions ce qu'il a
entrepris mais avec ma personnalité qui
n'est pas la sienne et avec mon
expérience mon inexpérience plus tôt il
faut donc que les les électeurs le
comprennent et je crois que ça cette
chose qui se fera facilement
les sages
les royals ont déclaré non conforme à la
constitution la loi adoptée il ya tout
juste quinze jours loi qui permettait de
développer l'autonomie des universités
autrement dit retour à la case départ
la loi savary de 1984 précisions avec
florence bukiya la loi autoriser les
universités à ne pas respecter la loi
une astuce que le conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas admis selon
cette loi si elle le désirait
universités et grandes écoles pouvaient
changer de statut organiser différemment
leur président ce conseil
d'administration régime financier
jusqu'à devenir autonome et seul le
ministre de tutelle pouvait leur poser
son veto or selon le conseil
constitutionnel il appartient au
parlement et à lui seul de fixer les
règles des établissements publics
pas question donc pour le gouvernement
de faire des expériences
nous pensions que les universités sont
toutes très différentes les unes des
autres et que chaque université
volontaires pour le faire allait pouvoir
mener à bien des expérimentations dans
le domaine pédagogique dans le domaine
du financement dans le domaine
du mode de direction des universités et
que nous prendrions appuyé sur ses
expériences pour montrer à la communauté
universitaire les possibilités
d'évolution déçu le gouvernement aurait
en fait voulu élargir les dérogations
déjà prévues par la loi lang de juillet
dernier
mais à l'époque le conseil
constitutionnel n'avait pas été saisie
aujourd'hui les syndicats universitaires
sont satisfaits de voir cette loi jugée
non conforme à la constitution parce que
elle remet en cause en fait l'esprit de
tarifs publics de l'enseignement
supérieur il mettait en cause le
caractère national des diplômes les
cette expérience de nouvelles
universités qui existe déjà
ne seront donc pas prolonger au-delà de
c'est ce que prévoyait la loi lang mais
dans un sursaut de fierté
le gouvernement annonce qu'il
s'attaquera à une profonde réforme
universitaire en 1995
si les échéances présidentielles le lui
permettent vous l'avez entendu ces
étudiants manifestaient notamment contre
les propositions développées dans le
rapport laurent sur la rénovation des
universités un rapport qui devait être
présenté officiellement aujourd'hui par
françois fillon le ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur mais
apparemment ce rapport risque fort de
tomber aux oubliettes de l'histoire
françois fillon interrogé par son parti
merlin tout le monde reconnaît en privé
dans la communauté universitaire qu'il
faut faire évoluer les structures de
l'université
on a aujourd'hui l'occasion de dire à
l'occasion d'une élection présidentielle
comment elles doivent évoluer
c'est un rapport qui n'engage pas le
gouvernement qui est destiné à ouvrir un
débat qu'on le lise et qu'on critique
est ce que ça ne veut pas dire que vous
prenez certaine distance par rapport à
ce rapport laurent mais bien sûr puisque
si j'avais voulu proposer une politique
de réformes universitaires qui soit
celle du gouvernement je n'aurais pas
demander à monsieur laurent de la sphère
de le faire ma place j'aurais fait des
propositions le gouvernement n'a jamais
dit qu'il allait augmenter les droits
d'inscription
il a confié à monsieur laurent et à des
hommes et des femmes de gauche comme de
droite
le soin de faire des propositions sur
l'avenir de l'université si la
communauté universitaire est unanime
contre l'augmentation des droits des
étudiants et des droits d'inscription et
bien il y aura pas d'augmentation des
droits d'inscription
je remarque que les présidents
d'université eux réclament aussi cette
augmentation des droits d'inscription au
moins pour les étudiants qui ont des
moyens financiers qui leur permettent de
le faire alors la question est posée
ouvrons le débat en refusant de débattre
et en caricaturant le rapport laurent
les organisations qui le font ne rendent
pas service à l'université parce que il
prône en élite et l'immobilisme
quand olivier guichard lors d'une
inauguration prétexte rencontre le 23
janvier 98 à sablé le premier magistrat
de la ville il y à là comme un parfum de
passage de témoin pour françois fillon
qui est en quelque sorte
intronisé dauphin du patron des pays de
la loire qu'il est à la fois long et
sans faille le chemin parcouru depuis
son premier mandat de conseiller
municipal sabolien lorsque joël le
theule est décédé en 1981 et que les
habitants fallait combler les ellipses
appelés sourdines demandé de me
présenter aux élections municipales
je suis tombé des nues j'ai réfléchi 48
heures et j'ai fait un choix qui a
conditionné le reste mon existence en 76
déjà il est attaché parlementaire de
joël le theule il gravit ensuite
rapidement les échelons de la politique
sarthoise et nationale 80 l'enfant du
pays devient au moment de l'arrivée de
mitterrand au pouvoir
le benjamin de l'assemblée nationale à
27 ans avec des idées bien arrêtées
nous avons toujours voulu nous adresser
à toute la france et à toutes ses
composantes et je crois que de ce point
de vue là il est juste de dire que le
gaullisme n'est ni de gauche ni de
droite
92 le député maire de sablé prend
d'assaut la présidence du conseil
général de la sarthe puis dans la foulée
devient en 93 et 95 ministre des
gouvernements balladur et juppé
ce professionnel de la politique n'a
guère eu le temps depuis d'exercer ses
passions la course à pied
vélo de montagne l'alpinisme de ce qui
est
mais je reconnais qu'avec le temps qui
passe je les performances ne s'améliore
pas et pour cet homme pressé qui s'est
lié d'une amitié indéfectible pour
philippe séguin la politique revient
vite à la une
bouleversement du calendrier électoral
apportées par les législatives
anticipées n'a pas encore fini de
produire des effets il est incontestable
que si les élections législatives
avaient eu lieu alors date les choses
auraient sans doute été différent même
si les conséquences de cette dissolution
dont on n'a pas fini par les lui trotte
toujours dans la tête une chose est sûre
pour reconquérir le pouvoir françois
fillon n'est pas prêt à vendre son âme
pour des alliances contre nature
françois fillon
alors qui allez-vous soutenir écoutez ce
premier tour n'a rien réglé en réalité
car les deux candidats qui se retrouve
au second tour sont justement les deux
candidats qui avaient choisi de ne pas
trancher la question fondamentale de la
ligne politique du rpr est ce que nous
sommes une formation libéral et
centriste une sorte de cd ou à la
française
ou est-ce que nous sommes au contraire
un parti républicain et sociales et moi
avec 25% des électeurs j'entends
maintenant continuer le combat pour que
le rpr affirme son identité républicaine
et sociale et surtout pour qu'ils se
réconcilient avec charles pasqua parce
que je pense que la famille gaulliste ne
peut pas rester divisé alors évidemment
il faut choisir et j'ai reçu les deux
candidats
je les ai écoutés et j'ai choisi
d'apporter mon soutien à michèle alliot
marie
pourquoi je les fais pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que leur et moderne parce
que c'est une femme d'abord parce que
c'est elle qui m'a donné le plus de
garanties que la sensibilité que je
représente seraient entendus et serait à
sa place au coeur du mouvement et puis
ensuite parce que c'est vrai qu'elle est
belle incarne plus le renouvellement
plus la modernité et qu'elle me semble
plus apte à continuer l'effort de
démocratisation de rénovation que
philippe séguin avait commencé et dont
ce premier tour a été une très belle
illustration clairement françois fillon
jean paul delevoye ont dit que c'était
lé candidat de jacques chirac de
l'elysée dont vous n'avez pas voulu
choisir le candidat de jacques chirac
je crois que tous ceux qui ont voulu
mouiller le président de la république
dans cette élection lui ont rendu un
mauvais service
la vérité c'est que tous les militants
du un fana de jacques chirac jean paul
delevoye
non c'était en tout cas ce qu'affirmait
son entourage tous les militants que
j'ai rencontrés pendant cette campagne
soutiennent le président de la
république simplement beaucoup d'entre
eux pensent que la gestion de la
cohabitation et en particulier la place
du rpr pendant cette cohabitation n'a
pas été celle qu'elle aurait dû pendant
la campagne j'ai notamment déclaré je
crois que ce télégramme de brest mes
concurrents proposent des recettes de
cuisine vous allez quand même rentrer
dans la cuisine et je vais faire entrer
dans la cuisine pour faire entendre ma
voix pour défendre mes idées pour vivre
en union vos concurrents comme je trouve
que la campagne qu'ils ont fait l'un et
l'autre étaient une campagne qui portait
plus sur l'organisation du mouvement
le sur les débats de fond mais quand
vous avez dit au sein de monde je
gagnerai si le rpr veut changer vous
êtes sentiment qui veut pas vraiment
changé c'est le sentiment qu'il n'ya
qu'un quart des militants qui veulent
vraiment changé et aujourd'hui pour moi
le pari c'est d'essayer d'en convaincre
d'autres alors par exemple vous avez
demandé une procédure interne contre
jean tiberi est ce que pensait que
michel marie va vous suivre je pense que
michèle alliot-marie devra si elle est
élue régler cette question dans un délai
très court parce qu'elles pèsent sur
l'avenir du rpr lourdement vous avez
vous êtes prononcés contre le projet de
révision constitutionnelle et du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
vous pensez que michèle alliot-marie
vous suivra et donc sera un désaccord
avec jacques chirac
en tout cas moi je défendrai la position
qui est la mienne et j'essaierai de la
faire partager au plus grand nombre
je pense que cette réforme est une
mauvaise réforme qui est contraire à
l'esprit même de nos institutions vous
allez faire pour rester hors pair vous
sentez proche de charles pasqua vous
êtes un fidèle de philippe seguin et
vous allez avec des gens qui sont pas
franchement sur vos idées et je vous
fais remarquer d'abord philippe séguin
est toujours au rpr et que nous pensons
toujours qu'il est possible qu'il
revienne d'opérer ans il est toujours au
rpo et mais ils reviennent à la
responsabilité des repères un jour non
je crois que c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui il a d'autres réflexions et
d'autres ambitions mais il est toujours
rpr il inspire toujours une bonne partie
du courant de pensée que j'ai essayé de
représenter dans cette élection
et moi je crois encore à la possibilité
de refaire du rpr cette formation
républicaine et sociale que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure je n'ai pas pu obtenir la
majorité des militants je continue le
combat et françois fillon vous êtes
favorable à des accords électoraux avec
le rpf
oui je suis favorable à des accords
électoraux avec le rpf car je ne vois
pas comment nous pourrions rejetée
charles pasqua qui était encore il ya
six mois dans nos rangs au profit par
exemple d'accords électoraux avec l'udf
qui sont finalement plus éloignés de
nous leur en fait avec patrick devedjian
avec les voix que vous représentez
michèle alliot-marie maintenant
quasiment assuré de devenir présidente
du rpr
si elle est élue considérez-vous après
tout ce qu'on a dit c'est un désaveu
pour jacques chirac je crois que tous
ceux en qui encore une fois ont voulu
donner une signification à cette
élection par rapport au président de la
république se sont trompés en vérité la
signification profonde de cette élection
ce sera quand même le choix
militant d'une certaine autonomie par
rapport aux entourages qui n'ont pas
aimé qu'on leur confie ce que la
démocratie c'est la première fois qu'il
y avait un vrai débat au sein du rpr et
on a voulu leur imposer un candidat ils
sont pas laissés impressionner
merci françois fillon les 35 heures font
l'objet d'un véritable réaménagement
l'assouplissement est inscrit dans les
projets du gouvernement et françois
fillon présentait aujourd'hui au
syndicales les premières grandes ébauche
qui apporte un certain nombre de
modifications sur le régime des heures
supplémentaires les syndicats se disent
déçus le projet sera examiné par
l'assemblée au début du mois prochain
françois vous donnez de tente de nous en
tracer les grandes lignes augmenter le
nombre d'heures supplémentaires et
diminuer le repos compensateur
sans que cela coûte trop cher aux
entreprises voilà l'objectif affiché par
le gouvernement raffarin
dès le mois d'octobre un décret va faire
face ils plafond d'heures
supplémentaires de 130 à 180 heures par
an vous pouvez travailler 39 heures par
semaine en moyenne dont quatre en heures
supplémentaires
ce contingent d'heures pourra même être
augmenté si les partenaires sociaux
signent un accord de branche pour le
paiement des heures supplémentaires si
vous êtes dans une entreprise de moins
de 20 personnes
les quatre première heures seront payés
10% de plus qu'une heure normale dans
les autres entreprises
ce taux sera compris entre 10 et 25% et
ce sera à la négociation entre patrons
et syndicats de le déterminer
enfin le paiement sous forme de repos
pour les quatre premières heures et
supprimer jusqu'à présent au contraire
il était obligatoire
ces heures seront donc tout simplement
rémunérés en politique on retiendra
l'alliance ouverte de nicolas sarkozy et
de françois fillon deux hommes qui n'ont
pas toujours été d'accord
la campagne pour la présidence de l'ump
les a réunis vraisemblablement françois
fillon devrait être un nouvel acteur au
sein du parti
lorsque nicolas sarkozy en prendra la
présidence mais quelle d'armes
un député ump doit savoir tout faire et
surtout chauffer la salle d'un parti
convalescent mais là le public est
conquis d'avancé par la fiche du jour
nicolas sarkozy toujours dans le geste
et françois fillon toujours aussi vrai
tish sur une même scène ça vous exact le
député y promenions mpla dans le fil
vous à merci les deux premiers faits
mains qui se tendent vers vous françois
le gaulliste social et nicolas le
libéral pragmatique se sont rapprochés
pour cause de conquête à l'ump
entre les deux la hache de guerre est
enterrée et nous nous sommes même
parfois heurter sans indulgence pour
tout dire
lui c'est nicolas et moi c'est françois
mais je veux vous dire qu'il est
rassurant de voir que le futur président
de l'ump ne s'entoure pas de sosies et
d'obliger déjà considéré comme le
président de l'ump nicolas sarkozy a lui
exposer sa vision d'un parti indocile
c'est à dire à son image parler
franchement
ne me demandez pas de rentrer dans le
rang
tout comme tant d'autres parce que ça
c'est pas possible
ne me demandez pas de moins aimé la
politique parce que la politique je ne
les ai pas choisis
c'est elle qui est venue me chercher
c'est pas ma faute je lai par coupe les
vivres de ma peau l'ump sera pour
nicolas sarkozy son laboratoire sur
l'observatoire
et si besoin sa plateforme de tir
[Musique]
voilà dans un instant on sera en ligne
avec dijon où nicolas sarkozy tient son
premier meeting de deuxième tour de la
campagne du deuxième tour avec nous
françois fillon je vous le disais qu'on
présente parfois comme le possible
premier ministre nicolas sarkozy en cas
de victoire
qu'est ce qui doit changer dans son
discours après ce premier tour françois
fillon il faut que nicolas sarkozy sait
que s'adresse à tous les français
y'a pas j'entendais tout à leur dire sur
votre antenne françois bayrou détient la
clé de cette élection non dans une
élection présidentielle n'y a pas des
français est dictée du df de gauche il
faut que nicolas sarkozy parle à tous
les français il va le faire il va le
faire avec le projet qui est le sien
sans modifier les orientations de ce
projet parce que ça ne serait pas
honnête ça ne serait pas mort à l'emploi
y aura-t-il un changement il va montrer
d'abord que dans son projet il ya ça il
ya une simplification au premier tour
elle est d'autant plus forte qu'il ya eu
un matraquage un peu dur d autre
candidat contre nicolas sarkozy donc il
va montrer qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
dans son projet qui correspondent à des
engagements qui étaient pris par
françois bayrou sur la modernisation des
institutions sur des réformes à
caractère économique ou des cailloux à
caractère social il ya beaucoup de
choses qui reprennent les mêmes idées
elle peut résumer ça en disant pour le
premier tour il est allé sur les terres
de jean marie le pen devant ses
électeurs pour le deuxième tour il va
aller sur les couleurs durant sa période
lorsque son projet sera le même et vous
verrez que vous ne trouverez pas de deux
choses nouvelles dans le projet de
nicolas sarkozy il ne va pas inventer
des idées nouvelles qui ne seraient pas
des idées qui correspondrait à ses
engagements au travail que nous avons
fait pendant deux ans pour essayer de
réfléchir à la manière de sortir la
france de la crise simplement il va
rassembler sur son projet et vous verrez
que son projet répond à a beaucoup
d'attentes des français qu'ils soient de
gauche d'ailleurs où qu'ils soient du
centre avec françois depuis trois ans
ils ne se quittent plus françois fillon
ex ministre débarqué du gouvernement
raffarin fait aujourd'hui figure de
favori pour matignon même s'il s'en
défend
non c'est pas je me prépare pas c'est
que
c'est il faut pas qu'on mélange les
étapes
autre hypothèse mais cette fois moins
probable jean louis borloo 15 ministres
une promesse de parité égale forte
concurrence à l'heure du choix il y a
les anciens michèle alliot marie alain
juppé et peut être aussi michel barnier
circulent les noms des fidèles comme
brice hortefeux ou patrick devedjian
parmi les jeunes qui montent xavier
bertrand rachida dati ancien porte
parole pendant la campagne
les secrétaires d'état seront nommés
après les législatives et pourrait
compter valérie pécresse ou nathalie
kosciusko morizet nicolas sarkozy veut
une ouverture vers le centre il
s'intéresse aux udf maurice leroy ou
christian blanc et vers la gauche au
socialiste jean marie bockel
depuis ce matin un nouvel homme accepte
bien volontiers d'entrer à l'elysée
claude guéant ancien directeur de
cabinet de nicolas sarkozy serait très
heureux de devenir le secrétaire général
il pourrait ainsi rester dans l'ombre de
son patron devenu président rapide et
sans chaleur la passation de pouvoir
entre dominique de villepin et françois
fillon s'est réduite au minimum ce matin
à l'hôtel matignon
le sénateur de la sarthe désormais
premier ministre après ses fonctions
avant de retrouver nicolas sarkozy pour
un footing au bois de boulogne
sandrine rigaux c'est à pied et sous une
pluie fine que françois fillon arrive à
matignon
il est à peine plus de 11 heures juste
derrière lui son épouse peiné la tapis
rouge et garde républicaine pour le
protocole sourires poignées de main et
embrassades pour les caméras sur la
veste de madame de villepin une
inscription en forme de clin d'oeil que
l'on peut lire de près adios bye bye
ciao ciao et salut
à l'intérieur les deux hommes qui ne
s'apprécient guère se retire pour un
tête à tête d'une demi-heure et à la
sortie de déclarations polies et
républicaine je voudrais bien sûr
également souhaité bonne chance à
françois fillon lui dire mon espoir est
ma confiance
il a tous les atouts pour réussir au
service de notre pays
merci françois et votre chance pendant
plus de deux ans vous avez dirigé le
gouvernement de notre pays
avec un style une passion et un
engagement qui ont marqué les français
je respecterai tous les engagements que
nous avons pris parce que la rénovation
de la vie politique est à ce prix
applaudissements du personnel de
matignon après avoir passé 23 mois ici
dominique de villepin a sonné que
mystique définitivement les lieux
deux heures à peine après cette
passation de pouvoir
scène beaucoup moins protocolaire dans
le bois de boulogne
nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon côte
à côte en plein jogging
une façon d'afficher leur complicité est
de faire passer un message
les temps changent aucun doute là dessus
félicitations de gérard holtz qui habite
le quartier et séances photos pour
terminer le nouveau président ne perd
pas une seconde pour imposer son style
il faisait l'objet de discussions de
négociations depuis maintenant plusieurs
jours en coulisses le président de la
république avait annoncé qu'il
souhaitait je cite la meilleure équipe
de france pour son gouvernement et bien
on en connaît désormais la composition
15 ministres cette femme
huit hommes dont un socialiste et un
centriste on y retrouve deux engagements
la parité et l'ouverture
javits imbert et voici le gouvernement
fillon 1
le premier ministre est en face du
président sarkozy lequel est entouré par
deux habitués du salon murat siège du
conseil des ministres michèle alliot
marie et alain juppé alain juppé le
numéro deux de ce gouvernement
écologie développement et aménagement
durables fameux super ministère imaginé
par nicolas hulot alain juppé
sensibiliser à l'écologie au canada se
voit bien à leur français jean louis
borloo ministre de l'économie des
finances et de l'emploi un ministère et
au fait là encore il aura la main sur la
stratégie économique tandis qu'à bercy
un autre ministre eric woerth sera en
charge du budget des comptes publiques
la grosse sensation de ce gouvernement
c'est lui bernard kouchner n'avait siégé
au tour de table de gouvernements de
gauche il se retrouve chef de la
diplomatie de nicolas sarkozy et
françois fillon michèle alliot-marie
aura toujours des uniformes sous ses
ordres mais plus les mêmes elles passent
de la défense à l'intérieur l'outre-mer
et des collectivités territoriales
là encore la place beauvau est en
quelque sorte coupé en deux brice
hortefeux l'ami de nicolas sarkozy
hérite du fameux ministère de
l'immigration et de l'identité nationale
rachida dati porte parole du candidat
sarkozy va en devenir le garde des
sceaux un ministère sur mesure pour
cette ancienne magistrate âgée de 41 ans
hervé morin ministre de la défense lui
symbolise l'ouverture vers l'idf
il était avant les élections un proche
de françois bayrou resserré et féminisé
ouvert voilà comment françois fillon
décrit son gouvernement
tout le monde parlait de l'ouverture
depuis très longtemps
on l'a fait et on l'a fait avec un seul
souci c'est de faire venir toutes les
bonnes volontés de faire venir tout les
hommes et les femmes qui ont envie que
notre pays se porte mieux
chacun est libre chacun a ses
convictions on ne demande à personne de
renoncer à ses convictions mais enfin
dans un pays comme le nôtre sur la
question de l'exclusion
sur la question des retraites sur la
question de la politique européenne
on doit bien pouvoir rassembler des
hommes et des femmes qui viennent
d'horizons politiques différents
le gouvernement fillon ce sont aussi des
têtes déjà connus ou expérimentés didier
bertrand sera en charge du travail des
relations sociales et de la solidarité
xavier darcos devient ministre de
l'éducation nationale
christine lagarde sera la première femme
ministre de l'agriculture retour au
gouvernement d'une proche de nicolas
sarkozy roselyne bachelot et là encore
un nouveau ministère qui couplent santé
et sports trois femmes font leur entrée
dans un gouvernement christine albanel à
la culture elle sera aussi y porte
parole valérie pécresse à l'enseignement
supérieur et à la recherche
rist in boutin au logement et à la ville
enfin l'ouverture trois socialistes ou
proches du ps eric besson pour la
prospective économique
jean pierre jouyet aux affaires
européennes martin hirsch haut
commissaire aux solidarités actives
deux autres secrétaires d'état dominique
bussereau et roger karoutchi mais ce que
l'on retiendra c'est d'abord les 15
ministres
le quinze de france de nicolas sarkozy
la campagne législative dans son fief de
la sarthe françois fillon mouiller sa
chemise mais reste premier ministre pas
de marathon rural seulement un meeting
ce soir alors que le candidat socialiste
stéphane le foll directeur de cabinet de
françois hollande a fait le tour des
villages dans une circonscription où
rappelons le nicolas sarkozy n'a obtenu
que 400 voix d'avancé au second tour de
la présidentielle sur ségolène royal
alloué stefan grand samuel beam ou au
théâtre ce soir à louer françois fillon
en représentation solo dans le premier
ministre en campagne sur ses terres vous
savez que je n'ai jamais perdu de vue là
ça je ne vous ai jamais manqué je ne
vous ai jamais trahi je ne vous ai
jamais abandonné voilà pour le seul
message d'affection
car pour le reste c'est bien le premier
ministre qui déroule le programme
présidentiel comme si son élection pour
lui ici ne faisait aucun doute
françois fillon veut apparaître comme
celui qui s'est imposé un passage obligé
par les yeux pour légitimer ensuite son
action gouvernementale
fort des bons sondages il taquine
volontiers ses adversaires socialistes
différence entre la gauche et la droite
c'est nous pro b
changement de décor disons beaucoup plus
intimiste
stéphane le foll et sa tournée des
villages dans la sarthe rural une seule
stratégie passait deux salles communales
en réfectoire avec ses chaises posées de
ci de là et parfois un potentiel
électeur à l'ong dans mon village à moi
à louer dans le canton de leur directeur
de cabinet de françois hollande
fin connaisseur de cette circonscription
il a flairé l'éventuelle bonne affaire
car en cas de victoire il priverait
françois fillon de son bail à matignon
si on arrive à battre fillon il sera pas
premier ministre et ça sera c'est un
signe clair qui sera envoyé quand même à
nicolas sarkozy au gouvernement et je
suis potentiellement un gros 20 sable
mais j'espère être un gros caillou car
au soir du 6 mai nicolas sarkozy avait
400 voix d'avancé sur ségolène royal
dans cette circonscription
mais les législatives ne sont pas la
présidentielle
le nouveau gouvernement fillon s'est
donc réuni pour la première fois ce
matin au lendemain de la nomination des
32 ministres et secrétaires d'état
tous les membres de la nouvelle équipe
était à l'elysée et pas seulement pour
la photo de famille autour de nicolas
sarkozy
le gouvernement en a profité pour
adopter le projet de loi sur le fameux
paquet fiscal
sandrine rigaux pour la deuxième fois en
quelques semaines la traditionnelle
photo du gouvernement mais la famille
s'est élargie 32 ministres et
secrétaires d'état et une promesse non
tenue celle de la parité 11 femmes
seulement mais pour elle un traitement
de faveur la photo avec le président
quelques heures plus tôt dans la cour de
l'elysée les photographes sont sur le
qui vive
le quatuor des affaires étrangères fait
une arrivée remarquée au tour de rama
yade la benjamine du gouvernement
trois anciens socialistes un autre
cliché n pas manqué celui de
l'improbable du christine boutin fadela
amara
il y a les habitués et les nouveaux
venus comme nathalie kosciusko morizet
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie après
plus de deux heures de réunion les
nouveaux ressorte visiblement ému
c'était un conseil des ministres au
sérieux
solennel avec une soirée importante donc
dans la république a bien fait
comprendre qu'il était important qu'on
se mette au travail et pour soit à la
hauteur
à plat sur nous
sa chance des réunions de ni [ __ ] ni
soumises plan a c'est très très large
mais c'est très intéressant et puis et
puis surtout c'est quand même là on
prend conscience que les hosties j'ai
pris une très grande responsabilité
un seul leitmotiv pour tout le monde au
travail est déjà un projet de loi adopté
le paquet fiscal qui prévoit entre
autres l'exonération des heures
supplémentaires et des abattements sur
les droits de succession
c'était l'une des promesses phares du
candidat sarkozy elle représente 11
milliards d'euros d'allègements d'impôts
après la rupture la fusion pendant une
heure et sept minutes françois fillon
s'est employé dans son discours de
politique générale à faire passer pour
sienne des réformes et des orientations
politiques déjà tracée par nicolas
sarkozy le premier ministre a également
revendiqué une entente idyllique avec le
président de la république où il entend
ainsi mettre fin aux critiques de ceux
qui le renvoie à un rôle subalterne
morceaux choisis réaction catherine ne
mangea laurenceau la parole est un
monsieur le premier ministre
aujourd'hui c'était son heure 1h07
précisément pour exister face à nicolas
sarkozy françois fillon avait promis
d'éviter le catalogue le copier coller
des promesses de campagne
et pourtant c'est bien une succession de
réformes qu'il décline avec un impératif
réduire la dette nous maintiendrons le
cap du désendettement et du retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
nous ramènerons notre dette publique en
deçà de 60% du produit intérieur brut et
nous rétablirons une situation
budgétaire à l'équilibré en 2012
françois fillon se pose en garant de la
rupture sarkozienne même méthode
réformer tous azimuts avec une priorité
l'université le gouvernement y
consacrera 5 milliards d'euros d'ici
autre mesure phare la construction de
cinq cent mille logements neufs par an
dont 120 mille logements sociaux
éducation logement santé pour financer
les réformes
le premier ministre compte sur une
hausse de la croissance et au chapitre
des institutions il promet de donner à
l'opposition un vrai statut au parlement
l'ouverture n'est qu'une étape sous
l'autorité du président de la république
je vous propose de poser les bases d'une
démocratie mieux équilibrées et plus
transparentes
une démocratie au sein de laquelle le
pouvoir exécutif agi avec clarté dans
l'unité du couple formé par le chef de
l'état et le premier ministre
mais pour françois hollande ce n'est pas
un scoop mais un homme et un seul qui
est à la manoeuvre
nicolas sarkozy omniprésent omnipotent
omniscient
le chef de l'état décide de tout parle
de tout intervient surtout évoquent tout
et quand et quand il ne le fait pas ça
peut lui arriver
monsieur le premier ce n'est pas vous
qui intervenaient c'est le secrétaire
général de l'elysée qui donne le
calendrier
sans surprise les députés ont voté la
confiance
la session extraordinaire est donc
ouverte dès demain l'assemblée débattra
du traité simplifié adopté au dernier
sommet de bruxelles
[Applaudissements]
au lendemain du soutien qu'il a reçu du
président de la république le qualifiant
de remarquables françois fillon était en
corse aujourd'hui premier déplacement
officiel du premier ministre sur l'île
est plus que ses déclarations sur le
dialogue possible avec les nationalistes
c'est une déclaration économiques qui a
retenu l'attention
françois fillon n'a pas hésité à
affirmer que la france est en situation
de faillite financière
explication texte avec alix bouilhaguet
et mathias seulement un toast à la santé
du gouvernement pour françois fillon
cette visite en corse commence bien
tellement bien qu'il martèle t objectif
réformer et sortir du déficit
l'état ne peut pas tout explique-t-il
sans complexe à des agriculteurs sur la
tête d'un état qui est en situation de
faillite sur le plan financier
je suis à la tête d'un état qui est
depuis quinze ans en déficit chronique
je suis à la tête d'un état qui n'a
jamais voté un budget en équilibre
depuis 25 ans ça peut pas durer on le
disait agacé d'avoir été traité de
collaborateurs par nicolas sarkozy
visiblement hier soir dans son
allocution télévisée le président de la
république a su trouver les mots de
l'apaisement
les relations entre le président de la
république et le premier ministre je les
dis elles sont bonnes par construction
le premier ministre il est là pour
mettre en oeuvre la politique
président de la république et quand un
premier ministre n'est pas d'accord avec
eux présentent des publics qui s'en va
qu'on a une telle identité de vues sur
les réformes à faire sur le projet
politique qui est le nôtre
qu'on est interchangeable sur le plan
des idées pour le reste il est président
de la république moi je suis pour les
ministres ça c'est pas interchangeables
une confiance mutuelle ouvertement
affichée même si dans le choix des mots
nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon ne
parlent pas toujours à l'unisson un
vocabulaire direct c'est la méthode du
premier ministre à ses yeux il faut des
images fortes pour que les messages
passent un patient déterminé à réformer
le style fillon se dessine peu à peu
bienvenue dans ce journal officiellement
c'est un ajournement de fait cela
ressemble bien à un enterrement le
gouvernement a donc décidé de renoncer à
la taxe carbone c'est françois fillon
qui l'a annoncé aujourd'hui elle n'aura
donc pas survécu à la défaite des
régionales
romain mais si sébastien laffargue
l'ordre jour officiellement elle n'est
pas enterrée mais la taxe carbone c'est
une certitude n'entrera pas en vigueur
le 1er juillet prochain
c'est ce que françois fillon a annoncé
aujourd'hui aux députés
les décisions que nous allons prendre en
matière de développement durable doivent
être mieux coordonnées avec l'ensemble
des pays européens pour ne pas creuser
le déficit de compétitivité avec notre
voisin allemand
en clair tout dépendra donc d'un accord
à vingt-sept hypothèse peu probable
la taxe carbone devait être pourtant un
temps fort de la présidence sarkozy
après la signature du pacte écologique
de nicolas hulot après le grenelle de
l'environnement michel rocard remet tait
l'été dernier ses propositions pour une
taxe sur les émissions de co2 jean louis
borloo en faisait alors la promotion
l'idée générale c'est que c'est bon pour
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages c'est ça
qu'il faut retenir
début septembre nicolas sarkozy tranche
la taxe carbone entrera en vigueur dès
le 1er janvier 2010 ça fait trop
d'années qu'on repousse à demain les
décisions qu'il faut prendre maintenant
quelques jours plus tard face aux
députés ump nicolas sarkozy évoque même
un choix historique comparable à
l'abolition de la peine de mort mais à
la veille du jour de l'an coup de
théâtre le conseil constitutionnel
censure le projet de loi retour à la
case départ
mais à droite l'opposition à la taxe
carbone est de plus en plus forte
avant même les élections régionales
nicolas sarkozy envisage un changement
de cap
la défaite enfonce le clou le
gouvernement fait aujourd'hui marche
arrière
la gauche crie au scandale de la
république n'a pas de parole je sais pas
si c'est une bonne nouvelle
voilà puisque c'est ça la seule nouvelle
ils l'avaient promis ils s'étaient
engagés à renoncer
il satisfait simplement une petite
partie de son électorat c'est pas une
réforme c'est l'abandon d'une réforme
une décision qui fait des remous au sein
même du gouvernement chantal jouanno
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie déclare
ce soir je suis désespérée de ce recul
désespérée que ce soit
l'écolo-scepticisme qui l'emportent
je ne suis pas en phase avec cette
décision nicolas sarkozy devrait s'en
expliquer demain en conseil des
ministres